février
1945 depuis 6 ans l'Europe est un
gigantesque champ de
bataille des millions d'hommes sont
morts mais cette fois la certitude de
vaincre l'Allemagne nazi est enfin là et
les Alliés pensent déjà à
l'avenir car c'est maintenant tandis que
les combats font encore rage qu'il faut
préparer la
paix Stalin Roosevelt et Churchill vont
donc décider de se
réunir rencontre aura lieu dans une
petite station balnéaire du sud de
l'Union soviétique c'est là en Crimée
que les trois géants vont imaginer
ensemble le monde de l'après-guerre lors
de l'une des plus grandes conférences de
tous les temps la conférence de
[Musique]
Yalta de Yalta l'histoire a retenu cette
photo mais quel chemin parcouru pour en
arriver là pourquoi ses visages tendus
chez Churchill Roosevelt et
Staline unis dans la guerre les alliés
vont se révéler divisés et rivaux dans
la paix pendant 8 jours du 4 au 11
février
1945 les trois grands vont se livrer une
lutte sans merci tant leurs intérêts et
leurs idéologies les opposent ayalta
c'est la dernière fois qu'il ils se
verront tous ensemble chacun d'eux est
alors un moment crucial de son propre
destin tandis qu'avec cette conférence
le monde va bientôt sombrer dans de
nouvelles
[Musique]
ténèbres 3 février 1945
après 7h de vol des avions américains et
britanniques partis dans la nuit
atterrissent sur le sol gelé de
l'aéroport de Saki en
Crimée à sa descente de l'avion Wiston
Churchill est enquilosé il a 39 de
fièvre mais le Premier ministre
britannique donne le change même malade
il est prêt à écrire une nouvelle page
de
[Musique]
l'histoire Franklin Roosevelt le
président américain lui aussi est prêt
malgré une fatigue
extrême sur la piste diplomates et
militaires se saluent a Yalta nombre
d'entre eux vont tenir des journaux de
bord grâce à leur confidence nous savons
ce qui s'est réellement passé pendant
cette
conférence leurs écrits racontent tout
ce que l'histoire officiel ne mentionne
[Musique]
pas
Staline n'a pas daigné venir accueillir
ses hôes à Saki son absence a déjà une
manière de jouer le rapport de
force les négociations ont bel et bien
commencé c'est donc Molotof le fidèle
bras droit du dirigeant soviétique qui
attend Roosevelt et Churchill au pied de
l'avion rongé par la polyomite Roosevelt
ne peut plus marcher à pied à ses côtés
chchill semble en position
d'infériorité l'étrangeté de cette scène
n'échappe pas à Lord Moran le médecin
personnel de Churchill qui s'offusque
dans son
[Musique]
journal le Premier ministre suivait à
pied au côté du président comme lorsque
dans ces dernières années un intendant
indien accompagnait la diligence de la
reine
Victoria et ce n'est pas la dernière
fois qu'en Crimé Churchill apparaîtra
comme l'intendant de
Roosevelt car déjà alors que la guerre
n'est toujours pas achevé l'Empire
britannique a perdu de sa superbe les
États-Unis et l'Union soviétique sont
les deux nouveaux géants du
siècle Yalta Churchill va devoir se
battre pour
exister
[Musique]
Yalta est à 150 km de Saki il ne faut
pas moins de 5 he pour y parvenir tant
la route est mauvaise et
sinueuse pour Roosevelt une nouvelle
épreuve
commence il était
paralysé pour voyager en automobile il
devait s'asseoir à l'arrière avec de
coussins derrière lui ter son dos et
soutenir ses jambes qui étent devenu
totalement
inutile c'était véritablement un voyage
très
difficile alors que la guerre continue
sur le continent européen le parcours a
été placé sous haute surveillance 160
avions de combat sillonnent le
ciel Ann betiger la fille de Roosevelt
qui l'accompagne dans ce voyage est
stupéfaite de voir les moyens déployés
par les
Soviétiques dans son journal elle
écrit tout au long de la route entre
sakita des soldats avaient été postés
tous les 300 m à chaque fois qu'une
voiture passait devant eux ceux qui
n'avaient pas de fusil nous adressai un
salut tous ces soldats russes femmes
compris étai chic et
droit par la fenêtre Roosevelt et
churchillcouv de
[Musique]
désolation la Crimée a été reprise aux
Allemands il y a un an à
peine près de 20 million de Russes ont
perdu la
vie 70000 villes et villages soviétiques
ont été
anéantis l'URSS a été profondément
meurtri par la guerre et Staline a
lui-même supervisé l'itinéraire de ses
hôtes afin qu'aucune destruction ne leur
échappe ça permettra à Staline ça c'est
bien sûr son habité d'une certaine
manière de culpabiliser ces deux
interlocuteurs en premier voilà nous
avons beaucoup de morts entendu nous
avons beaucoup de mort parce que vous es
pas venu nous
sauver
après 5 he d'un interminable trajet
Roosevelt et Churchill arrivent enfin à
Yalta en début de soirée Roosevelt est
épuisé pour lui le voyage a commencé 12
jours auparavant lorsqu'il a traversé
l'Atlantique en bateau avant de prendre
l'avion à Malte au total le président
américain a parcouru 8500
km Churchill
3200 et Staline venu train seulement
1500 comme si le nombre de kilomètres
avait un sens et que Roosevelt était
celui qui était prêt à faire le plus
d'efforts Staline le
moins la baie de Yalta n'a rien perdu de
son charme au 19e siècle c'était une
sorte de rivierra soviétique où tsar et
aristocrate venaient en
villégiature les participants à la
conférence vont être accueillis dans des
palais restés intacts
[Musique]
aujourd'hui avant que les négociations
ne s'ouvrent en février 1945 ils avaient
été entièrement
restaurés
en prévision de la conférence vous avez
eu un
réameublement très
rapide de choses qui sont venu de Moscou
par convoi entier pour rendre un aspect
hospitalier à tous ces palais qui
avaient souffert d'un terrible défaut
d'entretien depuis très
[Musique]
longtemps le choix de Yalta il veut donc
que ses hôtes nai pas à le regretter il
va les recevoir avec
magnificence il leur a réservé les deux
plus belles
villas le palais Livadia pour
Roosevelt c'est ici que se sont déroulé
les
négociations et la villa voronsov pour
[Musique]
Churchill ce soir-là la nuit éclaire sur
Yalta chacun des trois grands prend des
forces pour le marathon qui
[Musique]
s'annonce 4 février
1945 1ier jour des
négociations avant que les débats ne
commencent Staline effectue une visite
de à ses hôes à Churchill
d'abord les deux hommes ne se sont pas
vu depuis 4 mois lors d'une rencontre à
Moscou ils sont heureux de se retrouver
et font le point sur la situation
militaire les retrouvailles avec
Roosevelt sont elles aussi
chaleureuses le russe et l'américain
partagent un martini le péché mignon de
Roosevelt et il manque le citron Staline
en prend note et la fois d'après
effectivement il fait amener un
gigantesque citronnier ça les
impressionne parce que pour les Anglais
comme pour les Américains un
citronnier entier en pleine guerre et au
mois de février c'est quelque chose de
fabuleux donc ils sont littéralement
éblouis et en même temps ça sert à
montrer la
puissance de Staline
car sur le terrain Staline est en
position de
force depuis le printemps le rouleau
compresseur soviétique est en marche et
l'Armée rouge reprend des territoires
aux Allemands pour Staline l'heure de
monayer son effort de guerre est
[Musique]
venu à 17h les négociations commencent
enfin
dans la salle de bal du Livadia aménagé
pour la conférence tout est
prêt ministres et diplomates discute
entre eux en attendant les trois
grands Churchill est le premier à
arriver au Livadia avec sa fille
Sarah le Premier ministre est de bonne
humeur et coiffé d'une toque russe pour
faire honneur à son
hôte il va mieux après une bonne nuit de
sommeil la fièvre est tombée
Staline arrive à sa
[Musique]
suite devant les caméras les deux hommes
affichent leur
complicité Roosevelt lui s'est déjà
installé à la table de négociation en
toute
discrétion le même manège se répétera
les jours
suivants il a interdit qu'on filme ses
arrivées jugé trop
humiliante il devait être transporté de
sa chaise roulante jusqu'à une autre
chaise ce qui n'est pas facile quand
vous êtes paralysé à partir de la
taille les conseillers particuliers des
trois grands prennent place autour d'eux
car ils ne vont pas négocier
seul Churchill est accompagné d'Anthony
idden son ministre des Affaires
étrangères ainsi que du diplomate
Alexander kadogan spécialiste de la la
Pologne Roosevelt lui va s'appuyer sur
Harry Hopkins son bras droit son ami
l'homme en qui il a le plus confiance
mais aussi sur Edward stetinus son
ministre des Affaires
étrangères Staline a deux conseillers
principaux vieslav Molotov son ministre
des Affaires étrangères et le diplomate
Ivan gr dossiers sont sur la table le
sort de l'Allemagne vaincu celui de la
Pologne l'ONU et la guerre contre le
Japon sur tous ces dossiers la position
des différentes armées alliées va jouer
un rôle
[Musique]
déterminant depuis le mois de décembre
l'Armée Rouge a libéré la
la Bulgarie la Hongrie et la Pologne les
Russes ne sont plus qu'à 80 km de
Berlin ralenti par une contreoffensive
allemande les troupes anglo-américaines
elles n'ont toujours pas franchi
lein on peut dire que du point de vue
militaire les soviétiques sont nettement
en avance par rapport au occidentaux et
de ce point de vue-là tiennent le haut
du pavé ce qui peut avoir des
conséquences du point de vue
diplomatique en plus de cette asymétrie
sur le terrain il en existe une autre
idéologique Churchill et Roosevelt sont
deux capitalistes face à un
communiste pourtant ils ne vont pas
nécessairement faire front commun contre
Staline au contraire car en fait les
deux hommes sont assez éloignés
idéologiquement l'un de l'autre
Roosevelt apprécie Churchill parce que
c'est le vieux cheval de guerre parce
que il a tenu seul en Europe en 1940 et
qu'il admire ce type qui est encore
capable de performance extraordinairees
et en même temps un certain mépris parce
que il considère que c'est un vieux
colonialiste antédiluvien alors que lui
considère qu'il a des
euh idées modernes notamment la
décolonisation du monde Roosevelt a
besoin de Staline plus que de
Churchill car au même moment dans le
Pacifique les Américains sont en guerre
contre le
Japon les combats sont d'une violence
inouie et les Japonais n'hésitent pas à
envoyer des avions kamikaz sur l'ennemi
plutôt que de se
rendre sans l'aide des Soviétiques la
guerre risque de
é Roosevelt compte aussi sur Staline
pour participer à la future organisation
des Nations Unies qu'il veut mettre en
place sans l'URSS l'ONU ne sera qu'une
coquille
vide pour faire avancer son projet
Roosevelt est prêt à sacrifier Churchill
c'est un allié acquis qui n'a rien à lui
apporter le viit très mal il sait très
bien que Staline va exploiter à mort
toute divergence entre les Anglais et
les Américains donc pour lui c'est c'est
absolument désastreux car le Premier
ministre britannique soupsonne Staline
de vouloir installer des régimes
communistes dans tous les pays libérés
par l'Armée
rouge sans l'aide de Roosevelt Churchill
sait qu'il n'aura pas les moyens de l'en
empêcher
lors de cette première journée seul les
questions militaires sont abordées
chacun
s'observe dans le jeu tactique qui
débute Staline prend immédiatement la
main il propose que Roosevelt préside
les séances
plainères en le mettant comme
président quelque part on le on le
flatte mais aussi on le réduit un peu à
l'impuissance parce que il va être
obligé de servir un peu de maître de
cérémonie et pendant ce temps-là on
pourra observer on pourra réfléchir on
pourra négocier un peu derrière son dos
c'est c'est très astucieux de la part de
Staline cette première séance de
négociation était un tour de chauffe
rien d'important ne s'y décide mais les
Occidentaux ont compris qu'il ne serait
pas facile de faire entendre leur voix
face à
Staline alors dans la soirée chacun
affute sa stratégie pour le
lendemain Churchill réfléchit seul et au
calme admirant les peintures
d'aristocrate britannique que Staline a
eu l'atention d'accrocher au mur pour
lui faire plaisir Roosevelt lui élabore
son plan de bataille en compagnie de
Harry
[Musique]
Hopkins
deè jour Churchill arrive à nouveau le
premier tandis que Staline se fait une
fois de plus
désirer cette fois les choses sérieuses
vont
commencer la question de l'Allemagne est
en débat qu sort réserv à l'Allemagne
une fois d la guerre comment
l'administrer quelle réparation exiger
sur toutes ces questions les Alliés ont
des positions
différentes les discussions débutent sur
le problème de sa future
occupation depuis 1944 il était prévu
qu'une fois vaincu le pays serait divisé
et administré en trois zones américaine
britannique et
soviétique mais voilà que Churchill
réclame une 4è zone pour la France
il veut plus être seul contre ces de
géants qui en veulent un peu aux empires
coloniaux il veut donc avoir cette
complicité avec une autre puissance
coloniale Staline finalement bon
prince va dire les Français sont pas
vraiment battus pendant la guerre on
voit pas pourquoi ils ont collaboré ils
ont cédé très vite en 40 ils le méritent
pas mais enfin d'accord mais alors vous
la prenez sur vos zones d'occupation à
vous session ne lui coûte rien Staline
cède rapidement mais il en profite pour
demander un effort à ses alliés en
contrepartie il veut obtenir le maximum
de réparation de la part de l'Allemagne
l'URSS est ruiné les boges doivent
payer cette perspective revancharde et
frè Roosevelt et Churchill et cette
fois-ci les deux occidentaux se serrent
les
coudes si on pille l'Allemagne
et qu'on affame l'Allemagne pour faire
plaisir à Staline comment est-ce qu'on
la relève après ça sera forcément sur
nos fonds à nous donc c'est nous qui all
payer pour les réparations de Staline
donc c'est mauvais c'est pas bon devant
ce refus Staline se braque vexé il
devient
suspicieux le soviétique s'en prend à
ses alliés et se montre
agressif et franchement regardez-moi
dans les yeux pourquoi ne voulez-vous
pas la reconstruction est-ce a pas AR
penser he de votre côté vous occidentaux
à ne pas vouloir la reconstruction
légitime de notre pays pourquoi
voulez-vous affaiblir notre pays
voilà voilà pour la menace maintenant le
bluff Staline va sortir le grand jeu et
pour cela il va s'appuyer sur son
complice molotop avec lequel il forme un
duo sans
pareil les deux hommes sont des maîtres
dans l'art de la
diplomatie M c'est la version dure c'est
Monsieur nietet c'est celui qui n'est
pas rigolo qui qui va en général rester
sur les positions les plus dures et en
général justement le moment où Staline
intervient ça va être pour assouplir les
angles pour dire mais enfin tu exagères
pourquoi être si
dur dans le dossier allemand il faut à
présent avancer un chiffre pour le
montant des
réparations rien n'a été décidé par la
délégation
soviétique seul un minimum et un maximum
ont été
envisagés dans son journal le diplomate
russe Ivan maiskiy raconte la
scène Molotov qui était assis à la
droite de Staline se penche vers lui et
lui demande inquiet dois-je donner un
montant oui donne le montant rettorque
Staline lequel 5 ou 10 10 tranches
Staline c'est une manière de de montrer
que on est en discussion que rien n'est
totalement décidé et donc tout ça paraît
plus rassurant pour les interlocuteurs
qui sont en face 10 milliards pour
l'Union soviétique ça passe personne ne
dit rien Staline considère alors que le
montant est accepté les Occidentaux
n'ont pas osé réagir mais cette décision
aura de lourdes conséquences par la
suite car face à une Allemagne incapable
de payer une telle somme les Soviétiques
se dédommageront en nature et
démentelleront l'industrie
[Musique]
allemande après ce premier round de
négociation chacun des trois grands se
retire dans son palais pour
[Musique]
souffler comme à son habitude Staline se
plonge dans les dossier et prépare les
débats du
lendemain à son bureau aujourd'hui
encore tout est resté en
[Musique]
l'état au palais Livadia rosevelt lui
trouve un peu de repos et de sérénité
auprès de sa fille
Anna depuis quelques années elle est
devenue sa confidente et rosevelt
l'emmène partout avec lui
elle n'offrait pas seulement la
compagnie agréable d'une fille pour son
père elle était très au courant des
dossiers nous habitions à la Maison
Blanche à cette époque et je dirais
qu'elle était plutôt une sorte
d'assistante personnelle qui n'était pas
payée c'était un peu son bras
droit à 15 km de là au voronsof
Churchill est avec sa fille Sarah la
jeune femme est comédienne et depuis la
guerre elle est auxiliaire volontaire
dans la Royal Air Force Churchill aime
cette présence joyeuse à ses
côtés les filles sont ravies de
participer à la fois eux sont très
content de montrer leurs filles en
uniforme pour montrer que toute la
famille participe et en même temps euh
c'est très bien vu de l'entourage on
peut leur faire faire des choses qu'on
n'ose pas faire soi-même par
exemple
Churchill a tendance à se lever très
tard parce que il travaille dans son lit
euh il est tout le temps dans son bain
et on ne peut pas envoyer un aide de
camp pour le sortir de son lit ou de son
bain ça c'est pas possible par contre on
peut envoyer sa
[Musique]
fille le soir comme pendant presque
toute la semaine les trois grands vont
s'inviter à dîner l'occasion de
poursuivre les négociations de manière
moins
formelle le premier de ces dîners a lieu
au Livadia les Américains sur le service
mais les ruses ont fourni la nourriture
et Staline a mis un point d'honneur à ce
que tout soit
grandiose vous avez des dîners à 15 20
30 plats avec du Cavia esturgeon de la
crème la crème est rationnée en
Angleterre on sait même plus ce que
c'est on a oublié pendant ce temps-là le
peuple soviétique crève de faim mais ça
ça n'a aucune importance pour Staline le
le tout c'est de le leur montrer sa
puissance c'est la munificence
Georgienne et russe c'est je peux tout
en tant qu'autre vous pouvez me demander
ce que vous voulez psychologiquement ça
donne un énorme
ascendant je suis votre maître mais en
même temps je suis votre serviteur c'est
beau c'est beau et en même temps c'est
menaçant donc ça fait que on dépend
entièrement de la bonne volonté de
Staline c'est ça y entre autres
pour que ses autres se sentent à l'aise
et dans de bonnes dispositions à son
égard Staline a tout prévu à table
l'alcool coule à
flot on sait très bien que voilà si on
veut qu'une négociation aboutisse il
faut que l'interlocuteur soit en
confiance
et la boisson ça fait partie depuis
toujours des moyens qui sont mis à
disposition de la puissance invitante là
il y a tout jeu à savoir qui va boire le
plus je veux dire l'alcool a joué un
rôle à Yalta ça c'est ça c'est ça c'est
clair ce premier dîner a rapproché les
Alliés la confiance s'est installée les
négociations commencent sous de nouveaux
[Musique]
hospices
afin que tout le monde puisse récupérer
de ces soirées arrosées les séances
plainères ont lieu en fin
d'après-midi mais dans la matinée les
collaborateurs de Staline Roosevelt et
Churchill sont eux au travail pour
préparer les débats ils imaginent des
compromis possibles sur les différents
dossiers au trois grands ensuite de
[Musique]
trancher
au 3e jour de négociation le 6 février
le dossier polonais arrive sur la
table c'est le plus épineux de la
conférence c'est aussi le plus
symbolique car c'est en Pologne que la
guerre a
commencé les Alliés doivent mettre sur
pied un nouveau
gouvernement mais ils ne sont d'accord
sur rien depuis toujours Staline
considère que la Pologne représente
car cours de l'histoire c'est toujours
par la Pologne que la Russie a été
envahie Staline veut donc que la Pologne
devienne un pays ami en fait il souhaite
constituer un Glac protecteur tout
autour de l'Union soviétique afin
qu'elle ne soit plus jamais
attaqué les Soviétiques voul des état
tamp tout le monde saait que pour les
Russes cétait
de le politique
étrangère et quand vous y
réfléchissez si vous étiez un grand pays
comme l'URSS l'était vous ne voudriez
pas avoir des états hostiles à vos
frontières vous souhaiteriez des
état mais qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un pays
amis est-ce que c'est un pays amis qui a
simplement une politique extérieur
amical à l'égardunion soviétique et qui
en politique intérieure est complètement
libre est-ce qu'un pays amis de F en
aiguille c'est un pays qui va être
communisé c'est la grande
question pour les britannique pas
question d'avoir déclaré la guerre à
Hitler à cause de la Pologne pour
qu'elle devienne
communiste à l'issue du conflit
Churchill veut que la Pologne devienne
libre et
indépendante la Grande-Bretagne éta
traditionnellement amis avec la
Pologne les anglaisis beaucoup
avec les
Polonais il ne voulait pas qu'un pays
aussi important que la Pologne en terme
de commerce et de potentiel humain passe
sous domination communiste s'il pouvait
l'éviter pour Roosevelt loin d'Europe la
question polonaise est plus
accessoire mais elle a tout de même son
importance pour d'autres raisons il y a
6 milli de citoyens américains qui sont
d'origine polonaise et ces citoyens
américains votent pour la plupart
démocrat c'est-à-dire pour le parti de
Roosevelt il est donc très sensible à ce
qui peut se passer en
Pologne ces citoyens polonais réfugiés
aux États-Unis sont farouchement
antiommunistes la plupart d'entre eux
sont arrivés en Amérique avant la
Première Guerre mondiale mais ils n'ont
pas oublié qu'en 1939 Staline s'était
entendu avec Hitler pour envahir la
[Musique]
Pologne ces polonais d'Amérique tout
comme les Britanniques soutiennent le
président polonais Vladislav rakevic en
exil à Londres depuis
1940 le problème c'est que face à lui il
existe un autre gouvernement communiste
cette
fois ce gouvernement sous influence
soviétique est dirigé par Boleslav
bierou il il est implanté au beau milieu
de la Pologne à Lublin et se fait
appeler le comité de
Lublin le gouvernement de Londres et
celui de Lublin se haïsent car il y a 6
mois l'irréparable entre eux ses
[Musique]
produits août
1944 à ce moment-là l'Armée rouge est
aux portes de Vars
revic à Londres décide de déclencher
l'insurrection il veut que les
résistants libèrent eux-mêmes la
capitale polonaise avant les communistes
afin de garder la main mise sur le futur
gouvernement mais la roste allemande est
féros pendant 63 jours les résistants
sont
décimés
Siam Staline laisse faire et ordonne à
l'Armée rouge de ne pas
bouger 200000 polonais sont massacrés
par les nazis la capitale polonaise est
détruite à plus de 90
[Musique]
% 2 mois plus tard St illir le fruit mû
et installe un gouvernement communiste à
[Musique]
Varsovie a Yalta le comportement de
Staline pèse dans les négociations
Churchill n'a jamais digérer que le
soviétique a laissé périr les résistants
de Varsovie sans leur venir en
aide là il a compris qu'il avait pas à
faire un bon tonton bien bien veant et
que donc on ne pouvait lui faire qu'une
confiance très très limitée qu'il avait
effectivement à faire à un bandit
dangereux et que finalement même s'il
fallait se débarrasser d'Hitler
d'abord on allait avoir des problèmes
très comparable avec Staline après la
guerre mais à présent a Yalta malgré la
suspicion et les ranqueœur les Alliés
doivent former ensemble le gouvernement
de la future Pologne tout l'enjeu de
savoir quelle entité politique il faut
prendre comme
base évidemment du point de vue des
anglo-américains il faut construire un
gouvernement d'union nationale à partir
des différentes composantes politique de
la Pologne
antifasciste du point de vue des
Soviétiques et de Staline il s'agit
simplement
de finalement de partir de la base du
gouvernement tel qu'il existe à Varsovie
et de ajouter d'ajouter quelques
[Musique]
membres un bras de fer s'engage Staline
ne veut pas entendre parler du
gouvernement de Londres d'un autre côté
à chaque fois que Churchill ou Roosevelt
font un pas vers lui en proposant des
personnalités à faire entrer dans le
gouvernement de Lublin il refuse
pourquoi
accepterait-il Staline sait qu'il est en
position de
[Musique]
force les troupes soviétiques étaient
dans ces pays elles occupaient ces pays
même si on n'osait pas employer le mot
occupation quoi qu'il en soit elles
étaient bien
là d'une certaine manière l'influence de
l'Union soviétique était
inévitable les alliés ne parviennent pas
à
s'entendre petit à petit le ton monte
Staline est de plus en plus
agité à ses côtés Ivan maiski est
pétrifié dans son journal il raconte la
scène soudain Staline se leva et fit de
grands gestes avec son bras droit un tel
comportement lors d'une conférence avec
les TR grands n'était pas vraiment
approprié il commença à parler avec un
énervement
inhabituqu
trsit de très calme aussi sauf à
quelques reprises où il va s'énerver et
donc du coup ces moments là paraissent
d'autant plus importants le fait de de
se lever et de et de d'avoir tout d'un
coup un une tirade très très émotive sur
un sujet c'est une manière de montrer
très clairement à ses
interlocuteurs les choses sur lesquelles
il n'y a rien à
négocier la tirade du soviétique laisse
ses alliés
chaosk assiste à la catastrophe glisse
alors un petit mot à Roosevelt qui
préside les
débats pourquoi ne pas en finir avec ça
aujourd'hui dites que nous en
reparlerons demain il est
19h15 mieux va arrêter les frais et
tenter de repartir sur de nouvelles
bases le lendemain la maestria avec
laquelle Staline mène les négociations
saute aux yeux de tous oncle Jo comme le
surnomment les Occidentaux exerce un
pouvoir de
les
délég le soir dans sa chambre le
diplomate Alexander kadogan
écrit oncle Jo est le plus
impressionnant des trois il est très
calme et réservé quand il intervient il
n'emploie jamais un mot superflu et va
droit au
but le secrétaire d'État britannique
anthonyeden n'est pas moins
admiratif par des méthodes subtiles il
obtient ce qu'il veut sans avoir l'air
de s'obstiner
pourtant tout le mérite de Staline ne
peut-être attribué à son seul talent de
négociateur car ce queiden et kadogan
ignor c'est conc Jo fait espionner ses
alliés avant même que la conférence de
Yalta s'ouvre il était au courant de
tout la préparation de la conférence de
Yalta a duré plusieurs mois
à l'époque les services de renseignement
russse étaient très bien implantés en
Angleterre et aux
États-Unis nos agents nous donnaient des
informations complètes sur la manière
dont Churchill et Roosevelt se préparer
pour la conférence nous savions sur quoi
et comment ils voulaient discuter et
quelle position ils allaient défendre
durant toutes les
négociation pour ne rien rater les
services secrets russes ont également
truffé les palais de
micro et ça euh Churchill et Roosevelt
le
savent ce qu'ils ne savent pas et là où
ils sont naïfs c'est que évidemment ils
sortent pour les choses confidentielles
ils sortent dans le
parc mais dans le parc on a posé les
micros omnidirectionnels qui sont
partout il y en a dans les arbres il y
en a dans les frondaisons il y en a dans
les buissons et qui les conversations à
plusieurs mètres à la
ronde Staline ne prend pas ses écoutes à
la légère il ne veut pas en perdre une
miette il exige même que ses espions
viennent en personne lui rapporter tout
ce qui s'est
[Musique]
dit Stal demandait de quelle façon les
choses s'étaient dites il demandait même
qu'on lui répète les dialogues avec
l'intonation que churcheld ou que
Roosevelt avait prise
le dans la partie de poker qui se joue à
Yalta les cartes sont truquées Staline
connaît le jeu de ses adversaires il
sait exactement où il va là où ses
partenaires sont dans l'obscurité et
avancecent à
[Musique]
taton
au 4e jour de négociation il faut
finaliser le dossier
polonais grâce aux écoutes de la veille
Staline sait que ses alliés sont prêts à
sacrifier la Pologne pour faire aboutir
d'autres dossiers plus essentiels pour
eux pour Roosevelt ce qui importe c'est
l'enu et le Japon pour Churchill c'est
un dossier qui ne sera jamais abordé
directement à Yalta mais qui est
sous-jacent celui de la
Grèce le pays est un ancien protectorat
britannique c'est un enjeu stratégique
pour les anglais car la Grèce ouvre la
voie au canal de Sue qui leur permet
d'accéder à leur
[Musique]
colonie mais depuis 2 ans la Grèce est
proie à une violente guerre civile des
communistes tentent de renverser le roi
ils tiennent les campagnes et sont aux
portes du
pouvoir si la Grèce bascule dans le
communisme c'est tout l'Empire
britannique qui sera
menacé Churchill redoute ce scénario
catastrophe pour l'éviter il a donc pris
les devants et s'est livré à un
marchandage
périlleux en octobre
1944 4 mois avant Yalta le Premier
ministre britannique a rencontré Staline
à Moscou en tête àtête Roosevelt était
alors en pleine campagne électorale pour
sa
réélection profitant de l'absence du
président américain Churchill a alors
proposé un accord secret sur l'Europe à
Staline alors quand on parle du partage
du monde ça n'est pas à lialta qu'il a
eu lieu c'est à Moscou quand church
et Stal se sont
rencontrés le document griffonné sur un
coin de table est écrit de la main de
Churchill et anoté par
Staline comme deux épiciers les
dirigeants se sont chacun attribué des
pourcentages d'influence en Europe de
l'Est 90 % pour la Russie en Roumanie 75
% pour les Soviétiques en Bulgarie 90 %
pour la Grande-Bretagne en
Grèce
a Yalta Churchill espère que Staline
tiendra compte de cet accord et pour que
le soviétique lui laisse les mains libre
en Grèce le Premier ministre britannique
est prêt à lâcher du l'est sur la
Pologne et donc cet accord des des
pourcentages contraste évidemment avec
l'idée d'un Churchill intransigeent et
qui n'aurait absolument jamais voulu de
de compromis sur la question de de zone
ou de sphère d'influence en Europe
[Musique]
pour ne pas froisser Staline les
Occidentaux finissent donc par se
montrer conciliant sur la
Pologne au 4è jour de négociation
l'Américain et le Britannique lâch le
gouvernement en exil de revic et
reconnaissent le gouvernement communiste
de biout à
Lublin en contrepartie Churchill et
Roosevelt obtiennent que les ministre
non communiste ent dans le gouvernement
de
lubl stalengage des élections libres en
Pologne après la guerre ainsi que dans
tous les pays libérés par l'Armée
rouge ce mot d'élection libre sonne
comme une victoire pour les occidentaux
même s'ils n'ont obtenu aucune garantie
de la part de Staline tout ce qui
pouvait tirer de Staline c'était
déclarations de bonnes intentions et des
formules qui permettai de sauver la face
devant leur parlement respectifs
ils y sont à peu près
arrivés mais qu'est-ce qu'il pouvait
faire de plus mais comment imaginer des
élections libres quand le territoire est
complètement occupé par les armées
soviétiques c'est là qu'il y a une
illusion de la part des occidentaux car
en échange de ces promesses les
Occidentaux accordent une énorme faveur
à Staline il lui permettent de
constituer son Glac protecteur en
rattachant une partie de la Pologne à
l'URSS en compensation la Pologne
récupérera plus tard des territoires
allemands le pays effectuera ainsi une
translation vers
l'ouest dans le dossier polonais c'est
le carton plein pour Staline le
soviétique a obtenu tout ce qu'il
voulait ses alliés espèrent à présent
que Staline saura s'en
souvenir
ce 8 février il fait un soleil éclatant
dans le ciel de
Crimée rousvelt est nerveux car les
discussions sur le Japon doivent
commencer le président américain a
absolument besoin de l'appui du
soviétique pour mettre toutes les
chances de son côté Roosevelt invite
alors Staline à partagé à martini juste
avant la séance
plainère Churchill n'a pas été prévenu
la rencontre entre les deux alliés se
déroule dans son dos Roosevelt craint
que l'impétueux britannique ne l'empêche
de négocier librement et ne fasse tout
capoter et puis le président américain
croit aussi au vertuus du tête
à-tête il croit pouvit développer une
relation personnelle avec Joseph Staline
et je crois que Roosevelt sentait qu'il
pouvait influencer Staline grâce à cette
relation privilégiée qu'il
entretenait mais ça ça ne marche pas
avec les personne comme
Staline il n'imaginait pas à quel point
Staline était cruel et ex de
[Musique]
tout
au même moment dans le Pacifique les
Américains connaissent des revers
importants face à une armée japonaise
fanatisée sans l'aide des Russes
l'étatmajor américain a calculé que la
guerre pourrait durer encore un an et
coûter la vie à plus de
500000 Roosevelt est déterminé à éviter
ce bain de
[Applaudissements]
sang Staline le sait il fait monter les
enchères en échange de la chair à canon
soviétique il veut des territoires et le
maréchal est gourmand il réclame l'île
saraline et les îles couriles mais aussi
l'occupation de Port Arthur
d'en et une voie de chemin de fer en
manchouri les négociation ne pent pas
sur sal ni sur les couriles parce que ça
appartient au Japon et les Américains
sont tout à fait prêts à donner du
territoire japonais au sovi daen et P
Arthur c'est plus embêtant parce que ça
appartient à la Chine la Chine c'est
chanek chanek c'est l'allié des
ÉtatsUnis
et il a pas été invité à Yalta donc
Roosevelt peut se faire reproché
notamment par son Sénat de faire des
concessions à Staline au dépend d'un
allié ça c'est très
embêtant mais Staline tente à son tour
d'Amadou
Roosevelt avec son charme il parviendra
bien à trouver une solution et à faire
accepter les choses à
chunek Charles benolen l'interprète de
Roosevelt rapporte dans ses
Mémoires Staline dit qu'il était clair
que si ces conditions n'étaient pas
réuni il lui serait difficile ainsi qu'à
Molotov d'expliquer pourquoi l'Union
soviétique déclarerait la guerre au
Japon il est clair que Roosevelt était
embêté par cette
situation Roosevelt hésite mais face à
l'intransigence du soviétique
l'Américain ravale ses scrupules ce qui
compte pour lui c'est d'en finir avec
cette guerre va pouron et Arthur
Roosevelt sacrifie les Chinois il se
débroua plus tard avec chek une fois la
guerre
terminée le président américain
peut-être satisfait il a rempli ses
objectifs sur le Japon mais aussi sur
l'ONU cette nouvelle organisation voulue
par Roosevelt a pour ambition de
garantir la paix dans le
monde Staline a donné son accord de
principe pour y prendre
part la participation effective de
l'URSS est loin d'être acquise mais
c'est déjà un premier pas c'est une
grosse con
de lui faire admettre qu'il va envoyer
Molotof à Barton ha pour les
négociations préliminaires même ça c'est
une grande concession de la part de
Staline et Staline n'arrête pas de dire
oui si ça se trouve votre truc d'ONU là
j'en voudrais pas est-ce que je vais
envoyer molotop est-ce que je vais pas
envoyer molotop
ça il s'est très bien joué c'est un
artiste
[Musique]
6e jour de négociation ce 9 février 1945
Churchill Roosevelt et Staline peuvent
afficher leur bonne humeur devant les
caméras
Japon Allemagne Pologne sur tous ces
dossiers les trois grands ont trouvé des
compromis et chacun a obtenu ce qui lui
importait le plus Churchill s'est imposé
comme un égal face au de grand il asé la
France dans le camp des vainqueurs il
lui a fait attribuer une zone
d'occupation en Allemagne le président
américain lui a obtenu le feu vert de
Staline sur l'ONU et sur le Japon avec
Churchill arraché à Staline la promesse
d'organiser des élections libres en
Pologne et en Europe de l'Est après la
guerre mais c'est le maréchal soviétique
qui rafle la mise
incontestablement c'est l'Union
soviétique et Staline qui sortent
vainqueur de cette conférence de Yalta
Staline a obtenu ce qu'il souhaitait
concernant la Pologne et il a obtenu
plus ou moins ce qu'il souhaitait
concernant l'Allemagne en tout cas le
Prin principe des
réparation l'image d'une entente
parfaite entre les trois grands fera le
tour du monde
elle est pourtant trompeuse
ayalta Staline Roosevelt et Churchill
ont fait en sorte de s'entendre il
voulaient préserver l'alliance alors que
la guerre n'était toujours pas
terminée mais dans le fond chacun d'eux
a défendu sa vision du monde et ses
intérêts
propres de Yalta sont précaires ils sont
le fruit de compromis et ne reposent que
sur l'entente fragile entre trois
personnalités
d'exception au dernier jour des
négociations pourtant chacun veut y
[Musique]
croire dans la soirée les délégations
portent des toastes à l'amitié entre les
peuples et à la paix de
l'humanité mais cet espoir ne va durer
que peu de temps l'entente que les trois
grands célèbres va bientôt voler en
éclat à peine 3 semaines après la fin de
la conférence Staline viole les accords
de Yalta en Roumanie alors que l'armée
rouge occupe toujours le pays il
organise la prise de pouvoir par les
communistes
en Pologne à chaque fois que ses alliés
proposent un nom de ministre non
communiste à faire entrer au
gouvernement Staline le refuse Roosevelt
jusquel si confiant prend peur après
Yalta Roosevelt a commencer à déchanter
s'est aperçu que le Staline qu'il
imaginait ne correspondait pas tout à
fait au véritable
Staline le 1er avril le président
américain envoie un long télégramme à
son cher Staline afin d'obtenir des
explications je ne peux vous cacher
l'inquiétude que j'éprouve devant la
manière dont se déroule depuis notre
fructueuse rencontre de Yalta des
événements où nos intérêts communs sont
en jeu franchement je ne peux comprendre
pourquoi les événements récents en
Roumanie devrai être considérés comme ne
tombant pas sous les termes de notre
accord mais les mises en garde de
Roosevelt n'émeuvent aucunement Staline
sans le moindre scrupule le soviétique
déroule son plan et continue à installer
des régimes communistes à l'Est
Roosevelt s'éteint 11 jours après
l'envoi de son télégramme il ne verra
jamais l'ampleur de la
trahison Churchill qui à la surprise
générale perdra les élections en
Angleterre devra assister impuissant et
seul à leur échec a Yalta les trois
grands n'auront pas donné naissance à ce
monde de paix tant espéré le rêve de
fraternité n'aura été qu'un
leure bientôt les alliés d'hier
deviendront ennemis s'affrontant lors
d'un conflit d'un nouveau genre la
guerre
[Musique]
froide